>> Dagen: SOCIALIST
BERNIE SANDERS AND
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ TEAMING
UP TO PUSH THEIR LEFT-WING
AGENDA.
THEY ARE DEMANDING THE
GOVERNMENT DECLARE CLIMATE
CHANGE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THEY ARE CALLING FOR A MASSIVE
MOBILIZATION OF FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO DEAL WITH IT.
HERE IS BERNIE SANDERS RAMPING
UP THE CLIMATE HYSTERIA WITH
THIS COMPARISON.
>> I'M REMINDED TODAY IN TERMS
OF THE CRISIS THAT WE FACE IN
CLIMATE CHANGE ABOUT WHERE THE
UNITED STATES WAS A 1941 WHEN IT
WAS ATTACKED AT PEARL HARBOR,
AND WHAT HAPPENED AT THAT POINT,
HAVING TO FIGHT A WAR ON TWO
FRONTS, THE UNITED STATES CAME
TOGETHER AND WITHIN THREE YEARS,
IT HAD CREATED THE TYPE OF
ARMAMENTS PROGRAM THAT WAS
NECESSARY TO WIN THE WAR.
>> Dagen: DANA, WHEN THE WAR.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW WHY HE WANTS
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ TO HELP
THEM, HE NEEDS HER.
HIS CAMPAIGN IS ALMOST
INVISIBLE.
THINK ABOUT THE DEBATES.
NOBODY TALKED ABOUT HIM IN THE
DEBATES.
NOBODY TALKED ABOUT HIM SINCE.
HE HAD A PRETTY GOOD
FUND-RAISING NUMBER, NOBODY EVEN
TALKED ABOUT THAT.
HE'S GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
HAVE SOME RELEVANCE.
IF I WERE ELIZABETH WARREN, I
MIGHT JUST WANT AOC TO GO TO
BERNIE.
I WOULDN'T WANT THAT
ENDORSEMENT.
LET HIM HAVE IT.
THIS IS NOT WORKING OUT THAT
WELL FOR BERNIE THIS TIME
AROUND.
>> Dagen: I SAID THAT A WHILE
AGO, THAT IF YOU GET AOC'S
ENDORSEMENT, YOU OWN THAT
CRAZINESS OR WHATEVER SHE MIGHT
SAY THAT DAY THAT'S IDIOTIC OR
ORIGINAL TRICKLE IRRATIONAL OR
WHATEVER.
HOW DO YOU RUN HIM "I'M GOING TO
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE."
THE CANDIDATES ARE SAYING YOUR
GASOLINE IS GOING TO BE $6, $7,
$8 A GALLON.
WE'RE GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT
KIND OF HARD DRIVE AND YOU MIGHT
EVEN LOSE YOUR JOB IF YOU WORK
ANYWHERE NEAR THE ENERGY
INDUSTRY.
>> Greg: BEFORE I START, KUDOS
TO BERNIE SANDERS.
COMPARING PEARL HARBOR TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IS BETTER THAN
SAYING THE HOLOCAUST.
MAYBE THEY ARE LEARNING TO
CHOOSE OTHER THINGS.
PEARL HARBOR IS STILL PRETTY
BAD.
FEAR IS THE QUICKEST WAY TO GET
TO YOUR POCKETBOOK AND THEY TAKE
IN THE ISSUE AND THEY MAKE
TAXATION THE ONLY SOLUTION.
YOUR POINT, THEIR DEMANDS WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GASOLINE
CAN ONLY BE ENDURED BY THE WHITE
RICH.
IT'S A WHITE, LIBERAL, RICH, THE
TOM STEYERS OF THE WORLD THAT
CAN ENDURE THESE CLIMATE CHANGE
RESTRICTIONS.
IT'S GOING TO HARM THE LIVES OF
MINORITIES.
IT'S THE MOST ANTI-MINORITY
ISSUE.
BLUE-COLLAR AMERICANS AS WELL.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ELIMINATING
JOBS, RESTRICTING MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION, INCREASING
PRICES ON BASIC LIVING NEEDS
LIKE GASOLINE.
THESE ARE THINGS THAT RICH WHITE
PEOPLE CAN SHRUG OFF AND THEN
FEEL REALLY GOOD ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THEY HAVE A TESLA AND THEY
CAN FEEL GOOD THAT THEY HAVE
SOLAR PANELS BECAUSE IT'S
TOTALLY AFFORDABLE TO THEM.
>> Dagen: CARBON OFFSETS.
>> Greg: YES.
THAT'S IT.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND.
I LOVE THE SHOW BECAUSE I
LEARNED ABOUT WHITE PRIVILEGE
FROM GREG.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
>> Juan: IF I WAS WHITE, I
WOULD GET A TESLA?
CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS?
>> Greg: THEY GET DISCOUNTS,
JUAN.
>> Juan: NOBODY TOLD ME!
>> Greg: I KNOW A DEALER.
TESLA TOO.
>> Juan: YOU COULD GO WITH ME.
>> Dana: PAY FOR THE PRIVILEGE
BECAUSE OF ALL THE TEXT BREAKS.
>> Juan: THIS IS LIKE DOUBLE
JEOPARDY.
YOU'RE NOT TELLING ME.
I THINK THAT YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
BERNIE.
I DON'T THINK -- TALKING ABOUT
HIM, I DON'T THINK HE'S MOVING
HEAD OF THE CAMPAIGN BUT I THINK
IT IS SOUNDING THE ALARM.
WHEN YOU HAVE 90 DEGREES IN
ALASKA IN THE SUMMER AND YOU
HAVE HAIL IN GUADALAJARA IN
MEXICO, PEOPLE THINK SOMETHING
IS GOING ON.
FLOODING OF CROPS.
>> Greg: YOU CAN REVERSE IT.
YOU LEFT REPUBLICANS WHO SAY IT
SO COLD.
THANKS, GLOBAL WARMING.
IT'S THE SAME THING.
YOU CAN'T PLAY BOTH SIDES.
>> Juan: I AM SAYING SOMETHING
IS GOING ON.
LOOK.
>> Jesse: SOMETHING IS GOING
ON.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE?
>> Juan: 90 DEGREES IN ALASKA?
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT WEATHER
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> Juan: IT DOES HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO.
I THINK THEY ARE SOUNDING THE
ALARM.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH MORE
PRICE TO PAY FOR IN TERMS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY PROCESS.
I DO THINK IT'S A VERY PROACTIVE
TALKING POINT FOR BERNIE.
HE IS GOING TO TAKE IT OUT ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND IT WILL
RESONATE.
>> Jesse: LISTEN, JUAN.
IT'S OKAY TO SOUND THE ALARM BUT
THEN WHEN YOU SAY EVERYONE IS
GOING TO DIE IF YOU DON'T GIVE
ME ALL YOUR MONEY, IT'S NOT
SOUNDING THE ALARM.
THAT'S A FEAR TACTIC.
WE DO IT ALL THE TIME.
DEMOCRATS USE DEATH TO MOTIVATE.
THROWING GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF,
TAX CUTS KILL YOU.
POLICE KILL YOU.
CAPITALISM KILLS YOU.
THE WEATHER IS A KAMIKAZE PILOT.
BERNIE SHOULD APOLOGIZE TO THE
JAPANESE.
VERY INSENSITIVE ANALOGY,
COMPARING CLIMATE CHANGE TO
PEARL HARBOR.
VICKI OWES THEM AN APOLOGY.
>> Dagen: I'M JUST GLAD JUAN
DIDN'T SAY --
HE'S JUST STARTING A